art i think art in its core is the first
language like if you think of the caves
and the way
stories were first told
that that was the way we communicated
and i think it's still the only language
that we can all understand no matter
what language we speak i think when you
see an artwork it can move you in ways
that you're not even sure why it's
moving you it can tap into your soul
into your subconscious
and sometimes you don't need to meditate
before seeing an artwork it creates that
same effect
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with ctek
welcome to 20 minute leaders this
episode is all about art and
entrepreneurship and tech
meet sharona carney cohen the ceo of
dreaming
shawarna is an artist and entrepreneur
and she is also the ceo and co-creator
at dreamy a platform for commissioning
art with over 500 artists around the
world inspired by a vision memory story
or goals she also works with the leading
companies and hosts guided meditations
to the future
she is the co-creator of the big dream
one global art installation envisioning
the future of the world that has
traveled to 20 countries so far and in
april to the international space station
with the rakia mission she is an
advocate of utilizing our imagination
more
[Music]
i'm excited to talk about art
we just talked about how i need more art
in the back of my wall and so i'm
excited to to have a painting working
something with dreaming and
understanding the company better and
then you know the work that you're doing
is fascinating on a few levels both you
know on an entrepreneurial level but
then also on the
industry domain level the work that
you're doing with space and these types
of projects they're so cool to me and
i'm really excited to hear about your
personal journey as well as dreamy and
what you're doing with space as well so
thank you very much for being here thank
you for having me
so
tell us a little bit dreamy
what is it about
so
dreamy started actually
on a bench in watchfield um i met two
entrepreneurs
they are the founders today of wsc
sports so complete opposite of what i'm
doing
and i wasn't in the tech world i was
actually just after time out working
with your sister we just discovered and
i met them and i was really inspired
just by like what it is to be an
entrepreneur and how you can make a
difference but i wasn't so into sport
and with their help these two
entrepreneurs have even danny i started
a company called dreamy with the mission
of empowering anyone to become an artist
so anyone can send an idea a story a
memory a vision a fantasy and then
within two weeks have it turned into art
and sent to your home as a print as a
yoga mat as a phone case
but in its core it's basically
self-expression the greatest analogy is
a tattoo um
one in three people under the age of 30
are getting tattoos nowadays so i really
yeah wow
okay
i need to get on i need to get on that
as well then uh but
joking said i i i was thinking about it
at some point uh but if you're looking
at self-expression and this idea for
dreamy and you're talking about the
ability for any person to be able to
creatively express themselves creating
sort of a marketplace where some people
have you know their vision
some others have the ability to actually
make it happen
how does this originate where is this
where does this understanding of yours
come from
that self-expression could be an
interesting business model for this
world so i think from my end it started
just as like being a bit bored from
seeing selfies and photos of cats on a
news feed and i was a bit nervous as to
what's happening with the imagination
and like where where will the
imagination go like the more that we're
using screens and phones and watching tv
the less we're dreaming and we used to
like for example on the train look
outside the window and and daydream
that's how jk rowling actually came up
with the concept of harry potter and so
the less we're dreaming the less
imagination the less creativity the less
inventions um larry page actually claims
that he came up with the concept of
google in a dream so i think that's the
core of self-expression it's like who am
i beyond like what is my photo at what
nightclub am i it's like what am i what
am i dreaming about where how far is my
imagination gonna go and that's sort of
what we're mainly trying to tap into
so how does the you know customer
experience actually work end to end from
the moment i you know have something
that i want to create or i have this
idea to the moment where i hang it up on
the wall what does this chain look like
for you so you have different options so
you can if it if for example you're
creating a dream list which is like your
goals for the year ahead then you like
fill out different questions like
where's the place you want to be more
where's who's the person you want to
spend more time with you add colors that
you like from our color palette you can
add a song that you want the artist to
listen to while they're making the art
which is a really um popular feature and
then you can add your instagram and
photos of you and then it's all up to
the artist's interpretation so that's
also another kind of unique factor in
dreamy there's not like a
you know we do you don't have like a run
through and then have a potential draft
or a second draft like what what you've
commissioned is then what you get in the
artist's interpretation and like 99 so
far of our customers have liked what
they've received because they've chosen
the artist based on the style
how do you explain the fact that you
know so many people are enjoying or are
appreciating the what they received
because obviously you know even if they
liked the artist's you know style before
when they sent off their brief
what's going on in their mind is you
know they have this specific idea
perhaps of what they're imagining it'll
come out and all of a sudden it's coming
out something a little bit different
but they're still able to appreciate it
how do you explain that because humans
in the past aren't very good with the
disappointments from things that deviate
from what they actually expect it's a
really good question i think that's the
core of co-creation which i think as
well is like the next big trend in
general in
in social networks and platforms i think
most of the humans creating art on
dreamy are just really excited about the
fact that an artist on the other side of
the world is interpreting it and it's a
curated platform so it's not like any
artist can join dreamy therefore the the
standards are high
and
we're making sure before it's sent off
as well that it's
it's taking off all the dreamy boxes um
but i actually love to quote dan ariely
who's been an amazing advisor to me and
and one of our most reoccurring
customers because he actually said that
his favorite thing is this element of
surprise like so much of what you're
consuming today you know exactly what
you're getting whereas with dreamy it's
just a complete surprise on your
doorstep waiting for you
i love it
it's an element of surprise so where's
the company now in terms of you know
it's progress what's happened so far
where are you today 2022. so we've made
over 10 000 co-created artworks each
artwork is by the artist's name and the
dreamer's name the commissioner's name
drop reese to shipping
um
we've printed that art on phone cases
yoga mats as i mentioned and we've also
been working with a lot of companies in
the last two years it's like a great
gift for employees and also we've been
doing workshops to help employees figure
out what their dreams are what their
visions are for the future of the
company
um and art and offices in general is
just a nice thing to have especially
when it's created by the employees
themselves
and then recently uh thanks to the nft
trend we've also had a lot more going on
with our reproduction model so actually
from day one of dreamy
our whole idea was not to create like a
traditional marketplace so that when you
let's say commission an artwork and we
end up loving your artwork we offer you
the opportunity to join our secondary
marketplace in which some of the dreamy
art is then sold onwards and then you
the dreamer and the artist make money
every time from that thanks to the nft
world that whole model is a lot more
understood now um even though it was
working for us before and we had like a
physical gallery where we were selling
um a lot of these reproductions and
dreamies
fantastic fantastic so this obviously
goes hand in hand with
the other organization that you're very
much involved with that you also
co-found to co-created the big dream
which even is is very much aligned you
know also obviously around the idea of
art but also the importance of art in
our lives and the co-creation the way
that art can
help bring us together tell me a little
bit about this project so the big dream
started in tel aviv the idea was
inspired by how many
cynical dystopian visions people had for
the future of israel
and i set out to collect thousands of
dreams from people on how they
envisioned the future of the middle east
and the idea was to create a more
utopian vision and then with an amazing
artist and meat training we created one
artwork scanned it sliced it into a
thousand five hundred pieces puzzled it
together um
with yoga mats in kika bean and then
everyone came to do meditation on the
future of the middle east and since then
a lot of the reoccurring dreams have
come to life like the abraham
agreements and many other dreams related
to the weather like more rain seems to
be more rain recently um
and the whole mission of the big dream
is to bring people more together like
dreaming together what can we do if
let's say a thousand people's dreams go
into one artwork and then we did it a
year later in jerusalem and this year
we're doing the big dream world so
inspired by
the sustainable development goals for
the world in 2030
we've created
500 artworks inspired by 50 000 dreams
about how the world will be in 10 years
from now
and this video composed
how did you get those how did you get
the fifty thousand drinks
um
embassies around the world really good
tip if you're doing a project like this
approach um the ministry of foreign
affairs
really you had your go-to market was
working with the embassy so that they'd
go out and and get your those dreams
that's crazy um
and
also just different organizations
friends and all the location partners
that we had so for example in new york
it was in times square and zazz gallery
and tokyo is in the shibuya crossing in
norway it was in this beautiful snow
location in a town called hammar so the
whole town of hammer we're like
collecting dreams from people around
norway
most of the dreams are very much similar
to each other no matter where people are
around the world um for me it was
interesting that you know so many of us
in the middle east dream for peace for
example and only now recently some of
the artists are like oh now i understand
that dream like for them it didn't make
sense when we first started this project
so it's interesting as well to see like
how
the politics of the world also affect
different people's dreams
um
and the last location that it's
traveling to in 10 days is the
international space station so it will
be projected there with the rakia
mission and atan steva who's the second
israeli to go to space
incredible so so what is that what does
it mean that is going to be
projected during the is in the
international space station so
i'll start with why and then and then
i'll explain what um it started with a
meet eitan son who's actually the one
who
taught me a lot more about the
sustainable development goals and when
amy and i were talking about how
it'd be nice to kind of express these
goals in a kind of more popular way
sometimes when people are looking at the
un's sustainable development goals
they're like oh wow how would i even get
close to being involved in one of those
in achieving one of those so that's when
we started thinking okay let's create
the individual artworks and how amazing
would it be to send them to space so
that while the dreams are being
projected in space people will be able
to see if their dream is in real time
being projected according to where the
space station is around the world
because it travels 16 times around the
world every day um so you'll be able to
see a map eitan will be interacting with
that map in real time live like through
a camera
and
people will be able to see oh my dream
about
floating on water for the rest of my
life is dreamt in 18 other locations
around the world like there's an
algorithm that shows the similar dreams
through nlp
um so the whole idea is like to connect
between the world's dreams to remind
people that most of us have the same
dreams and to turn them into art to show
it through a more universal language
amazing where does it know this idea of
art obviously that's like the essential
theme here across
everything we've done well you know what
is the significance of art i think art
in its core is the first language like
if you think of the caves and the way
stories were first told
that that was the way we communicated
and i think it's still the only language
that we can all understand no matter
what language we speak i think when you
see an artwork it can move you in ways
that you're not even sure why it's
moving you it can tap into your soul
into your subconscious
and sometimes you know you don't need to
meditate before seeing an artwork it
creates that same effect
and i think it's a really educational
tool as well i think many people learn
from themselves about themselves when
they get their dreamy artwork because
you're sitting there and you're just
looking at all the different layers of
it and all the different interpretations
and so at the end you know if you're
looking at art you know in its role
today obviously it's it's a change over
time and the way we interact with art
has changed as well do you expect to
just to change the way we interact with
art is it going to play a more or less
significant part of our lives as as
humans as we as we go throughout the day
you think so i definitely think every
team now is going to want a
art director graphic designer as like a
co-founder um i definitely you know if
i'm thinking about like high tech i
think
design and art and the way things look
um are crucial for how you tell a story
for how you express something um i think
with the whole trend with nfts while a
lot of people are still confused about
it i think there is a lot of value you
know like digital artists in my opinion
are as amazing as watercolor or oil
painting artists um at the same time a
lot of people are obviously like trading
in nfts just because they're trading but
there are lots of crypto native artists
that are in it just for the art um and i
think the biggest trend if i'm going
back to what i said at the beginning is
more co-creation and i think art does
lie in the heart of that so i think as
humans we're going to constantly want to
more and more so co-create with other
people and i think art is at the heart
of creation so yeah
and if you're looking at it in the
business like dream
you know what what is sort of your
vision
how do you see this company evolving
over time now
to where you know and what what's the
goal with this goal really the goal in
like 10 years is that
firstly in your house and in your office
all the art that surrounds you is
created by you or your friends or people
that you know
and secondly that you can make money
from art that you've made with your own
imagination so potentially i'll be
wearing a t-shirt with an artwork
inspired by a poem that you wrote and we
as humans will be constantly co-creating
and constantly generating capital from
each other's imaginations and growing
together through our imaginations
so so now obviously that that's obvious
that's an amazing uh that's an amazing
vision and now more tangibly about you
know the strategy to actually get it to
run as i'm not sure as an entrepreneur
now you know what what are the biggest
challenges that you're facing with this
obviously you're creating a marketplace
maybe the supply and demand on both
sides so you need to have a good
experience for both the artist but also
for the person who's who's envisioning
it and they obviously need to have a
complicated logistics chain
of ideation to to shipping which is
obviously non-trivial either especially
with today's expectation for a two-day
delivery or whatever it may be what are
the biggest challenges that you're
facing as an entrepreneur with this be
honest the biggest challenge right now
is the scale and i'm
looking for a ceo right now i've
understood that i'm not that person
which of course is sometimes hard for us
to admit as entrepreneurs um i'd like
leon is like creative director head of
business development
um i definitely believe that dreamy can
scale like 10 times and slowly but
surely i've been getting there but i'd
say that is my biggest challenge because
in terms of the product in terms of the
community in terms of the marketing i
figured out how to do it as well with
the b2b and like you know selling it to
corporates and then those
the corporate clients indirectly then
become the
the new
consumers um so now it's just a matter
of finding a ceo for drewmy
it's a very
weird idea right to say okay maybe i'm
not the right person for this role let's
find somebody who may be more suited was
that easy for you this process of
coming to that conviction or that
understanding i think being an
entrepreneur in general as you know is
not easy so i think making decisions is
ten times
more easy it's ten times easier so i
think
the process of
pretending even subconsciously i can do
this i can be the ceo was the challenge
the moment i understood that i'm not the
person to be the ceo i think is when it
became a bit easier
and i'm definitely looking for someone
that's had experience that's had their
own company that scaled it has
potentially even had an exit that's now
looking to join something potentially in
the self-expression world in the art
world
to take it to the next level
right i'm sure it's not it's it's it's
not a trivial thing to
to to do that right i mean especially
how many paintings have you already
shipped you said
over ten thousand so you still really
know it's a rushing machine and i'm sure
that that's a and i have to say i'd say
it's an amazing ability to come and say
okay this is what the company needs this
is how we can get it to be 10x and yeah
i can learn along the way and i can but
you know what maybe there's somebody
who's done this before that i can learn
from
and you know the word you know life is
long and
sure as an entrepreneur you don't build
one venture you build constantly new
ventures and so this is something that
i've been thinking about myself recently
you know who is the right ceo for some
of these companies and when is the right
time to be an entrepreneur what is the
right thing to be a ceo they're not
necessarily two of the same things what
do you enjoy most about this whole
process by the way i really like what
you just said like definitely not being
an entrepreneur is not the same as being
a ceo um i think i enjoy the most just
hearing customers reactions from when
they've received their artworks to the
extent of like
two of my best friends have actually
proposed to their husbands today with
dreamy artworks um
and just the husband's reactions to
receiving those artworks hearing about
someone who like a husband who created a
dreamy for his wife who had leukemia and
over time she recovered and they shared
that seeing that artwork in front of
them every day just really help them i
think
it's just the really human side of being
the entrepreneur in a business like this
that it is so human orientated of course
it has its tech elements um but that's
been like the highlights when you're
kind of reminded that you're doing
something that helps someone or make
someone smile
it sounds easy that's the truth
sharana thank you so much this was
awesome this is so
enlightening and
i love the model and i love the vision
of how you see the world beyond you know
the business side or whatever that is
but
the the vision of how the world
is and how do we continue the
self-expression with co-creation i think
that's awesome so thank you very much
and stay safe and stay healthy
[Music]